hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm hanging out with my friend ro
hello and this is a very very
interesting video you know this is one
of those things we're in the comments
below you guys are gonna be saying you
guys have run out of my peers do you not
have any video ideas and the answer is
actually I didn't have any and this was
the best that I could come up with but
just seen at the store and she's so
creative and she's going through the
store aisles if you text again what
about this idea and I was like yes I
show up to ROS house with 4 potatoes
some Barbie dolls a stapler some
lipstick she's like wait I've got a way
to elevate this idea wait I didn't tell
me idea yet oh oh oh ok what what are we
doing what are we doing today we are
going to carve each other's faces into
potatoes and the best resemblance of
each other wins and you guys are gonna
be the judge of who wins because we
won't be able to we won't we're both
such our teeth yes so we won't be able
to tell I will have to put one of the
YouTube polls so you guys can vote on
who you think is the best so this is
going to be very very very exciting and
the winner will not get baked in the
microwave
[Music]
so what do you got over here all right
so I have some fondant tools that I
thought would be helpful when sculpting
a potato and I also got some clay
sculpting tools this is taking it to an
entirely other level I mean I was just
picturing stabbing some eyes I also got
edible googly eyes we have large and
small have some chalk if we want to draw
stuff on us pipe cleaners fuzzy balls
gems hot glue guns so we can really get
creative with these potatoes
I look down check my email in two
seconds later Roe has bought an entire
craft store it had this table well I
guess we should get started I mean which
one do you think would look most like me
okay well let me pull them up we got a
friend one that's most like your face
now when you take those quizzes online
what do they say the shape of your faces
oh there's like around the square a
heart an oval I think I'm a moon face
that I don't even know what I am like
when you see a moon and see it cheesin I
just think mine's a circle isn't it or
is it a square not a square
let me look at you Lucy which I feel
like this is little it's a little tater
it's maybe that's me yeah this isn't to
be you know this is lopsided just steam
so this is not you not you this is more
you it needs to be rounder this one's
real lumpy hmm
but it's nice and round yeah what do you
think we can all I want to go with this
one this one's the most cuz you're very
symmetrical face that's so I think this
is your potato this is you this is you
because it's little cute and we have
another potato which we can use and cut
up and add to our other potato so this
is really I don't know what's gonna
happen at all I don't know how to sculpt
I don't need something I'm sorry I can
barely even whenever you're presented
with a pumpkin and then like carve this
pumpkin I'm like
those competitions online or it's like
log carving competitions while carving
yeah they take like a stuff like a log
and they and they do art it's it's
really impressive and I'm wondering can
you do that with a potato do you think
people do that actually let's look at
potato carbon yeah asking this ask
google potato carving because this was a
genuine idea that I had in my mind
because I've really wanted to do a fun
video for Thanksgiving and I'm not
really good at cooking using mashed
potatoes Thanksgiving you know what I
did I made mashed potatoes and I just
threw all the potatoes into the blender
okay I'm gonna need the stick
you know what it didn't work because
when I went to pour my mashed potatoes
out oh there's a full potato right there
I got no recipe I'll give you good
potato recipe I made mashed potatoes
there's some potato carving going on
look whoa
how do they do that Oh while you're
watching Wow are using these tools they
are the clay tools now I feel defeated
already know how don't worry we can do
this I have faith and I thought since
you know we would probably want to put
hair on our potatoes I guess this Barbie
dolls a little bit like my color it's
like brown with some red in it I think
that was you like a few months ago maybe
when you had the more reddish color and
they're pretty on point Justine and this
is just a basic blonde which I feel like
it's a little too blonde but what her
she's got and that's like really that's
like daenerys targaryen platinum i don't
like we can just cut the hair because i
don't want to ruin the doll because it's
a very nice doll that we could donate
and somebody else can have that's really
sweet
yeah if you guys are I don't know where
you're doing it I love to donate to
Goodwill but if you guys are at Goodwill
and you see two dolls with little pixie
cuts there from this video yup
okay Wow in it there's a lot of tools
here I've got some good ingredients in
my fridge - yeah we make these
afterwards I got the toppings oh I got
potato topping these are sharp - Justine
you might like this this is like a mini
knife get it this looks like something I
see if a dentist
I've never seen an individually wrapped
potato me either and that's why I was
like this is cool and triple washed okay
okay I got a color on I got a pic where
noses I'm gonna pick where you're okay
it's here do we just go for it I guess I
honestly have no idea what I'm doing
here this weird nose needs to be oh oh
oh that's okay you can break my gosh no
no no that's fine that's a that's fine
okay Ben - back nothing has happened
okay we need it now let me see here wait
um okay major nose too big
um I need it okay this was supposed to
look like a contoured nose I was trying
to contour like a potato your eyes are
very deep set I'm so sorry
Wow Justine can you cut her free like
kidnapped Barbie all the gunner's she is
really in there who's gonna be you if
you got like a pixie cut okay okay back
you're just gonna do this give her a
chop and it's gonna be a really cool
fade I don't know I'm so nervous
oh my gosh I should always should've
done it the other way cuz now this is a
mullet this is party dusty this is she's
professional in the friend a friend yeah
oh my gosh so great now I got to glue
your hair on I'm trying to make a nose
let's get that hair on there and the
other half gotta lay the other way look
at you
when I was hoping for Wow
this isn't also not good good the glue
only six in the first layer I got a
Glynnis on in layers I got a like try to
form some of this glue to the to the
nose I don't want you to be offended
because that I'm okay okay it's just hot
dude elf one Justine I'll never be
offended don't ever I'm trying to give
you gorgeous hair I'm trying to give you
luscious gorgeous locks like Goldilocks
I'm trying to give you Goldilocks here
here it's just gonna I gotta build it I
feel like I'm gonna pause everything I'm
doing and just watch what you're is this
incredible Justine I'm gonna make you
look so good just wait till the end it
really is now I I just I have glued your
hair to myself I have hot glued you guys
this my gosh he went to Jared hello
okay now I got two options here I got
googly eyes are they blue or green i
canna have to tell the day Justine I
want to say blue but there's a bunch of
green in there but it's blue but there's
a bunch of green yeah they change colors
depending upon how much caffeine I've
had today really I just made that up
oh they do change colors so sometimes
you wear pigtails right like yeah I'm
not like that often but I've only seen
it right yeah I do I really liked the
pigtail so I'm just gonna the problem
too is I watched that video of that guy
carving and he was doing a lot of things
oh good at it oh okay your haircut is a
way better than mullet like that
actually looks good like she's fashion
yeah that's really cute let me okay
here's green I'm gonna shade your eyes
here's green I'm gonna staple your head
ripped up shady tree green let me add a
little blue blue green here we go
um anyway I'm gonna try to glue your
hair on I think that this works I need
to see I need a gym I need a gym Oh
quick quick
so many is your favorite color pink I
like pink
oh god that's hot I also like yellow
okay look at Justine's eyes they're
green with a little bit of blue not are
they blue with a little bit of green we
don't know they're both this is gonna be
actually my new Twitter profile pic now
we need some little cute oh yes rosy
cheeks this is the best ever bringing
about glue guns are really just like jam
it in there yeah do I just yeah here
here okay okay and it won't it will it
will latch on your latch on thank you
this is really coming together
we've got Justine's blonde hair and the
gorgeous eyes the green blue eyes and
your high cheekbones but the blush well
I've got a lot of things going on over
here so I hope that you're excited for
it I'm really excited okay now I got to
figure out your nose because I really
tried to contour it that's cute
it's a way cuter than what I got I need
to figure out your nose oh I thought I
was gonna you know when like makeup guru
artists they like contour the nose yes
so I thought oh I'm gonna do this
contour did it not we're not [ __ ] no now
it looks like a bird
well I'm filling your eye sockets with
hot glue so I hope that you're enjoying
it well let me put on some eyelashes you
need some eyelash idea
you look like an angry bird why is that
I don't know I feel like I got to put a
little more hair up here because it's
like you're missing like like we're here
you know yeah like oh yeah
oh no use it this helps Oh
oh boy oh gosh you don't what I'm gonna
move up your mouth it's gonna be right
here
ah hot glue is hot yeah you need some
lipstick here I want to put on some so I
think maybe I'm gonna just see if like I
could put this outfit on you oh you
think it will family no looking oh this
is a great color combo I wish it would
fit in this outfit but I just don't
think you're gonna fit in this have you
worked with this I can work with this
you can work with babies let me see if I
can tease a home you know what there's
velcro yep maybe I can get the velcro
yep this yeah this is a way better idea
than my camo idea for you this looks
really good like if I were a fashionista
which obviously I am yes yes oh my gosh
you're adorable
I just couldn't paint your lips do you
like your shoes I love heels
you know this is good because excuse my
girl doesn't have heels on the nose
situation is beginning to be a problem
here this is gonna be really cute do you
need an ice cube nice coffee pudding out
of it you put your feet AHA put your
fingers on it ladies and cool okay I
hear you Lombardi let me put you gonna
get you on your body let me get this off
oh gosh okay now watch your fingers on
here nice and cold nice and cold it's a
really cold drink I said I said look at
your shoes it's like you I mean I have
to say worth it look at that shoes
looking good it's worth the oh jeez
maybe not worth that no no maybe
nothing's worth there I'm like I really
got no doubt long as I got walking in a
spider way oh the accessories were too
much Justine what is the age on glue
guns I don't know but I think we went to
extra we should just stuck with the face
this is really good are you okay yes but
are you okay here let me help
oh no it's not helping oh my gosh okay
I'm actually pretty surprised this is a
lot better than I thought it was gonna
look which is not saying very much I
can't stop touching it wait I say I sit
there is hair all over you it looks like
you have like a dog that is shedding
everywhere but it got me it's your hair
well I gotta add a little bit of blush
on here for you this is the power the
power that were using it's looking at
I just rub it in a little bit right here
okay what I add a light art is if
anybody's interested its fashion this is
from being really good this is from the
new Kylie Jenner lip kit yep I think I'm
ready okay cuz I want to show you mine
because I am ready just okay you first
potato Justine is completely done let me
show you off what I got ready okay oh I
know look good I'm so glad you got the
shoes look at those shoes she's a beaut
let me walk you through it no I gorgeous
blonde hair luscious locks there's a lot
of blonde hair to second feature we have
your green blue eyes or blue green eyes
because she's got green eyes with a lot
of blue in it or blue eyes a lot of
green in it something something kind of
like that so I've shaded it so he's got
brilliant colors I try to contour your
nose what I covered it up that looks
good festive and then we've got your
high cheekbones nice cheekbones and your
rosy cheeks beautiful lips and then your
little outfit and at the bottom she's
wearing flats because that's just seen
likes to be cozy and sneakers are flat
so yeah we got your flats this is you
just team pretend I love it and I like
the pink little outfit well I would say
that's an A+ yes definitely nailed it
and this is my borough potato so what
I've got here is I know you like wearing
different colored lipsticks so you
always look very fashionable so I went
with weight today we use the elf palette
I added some nice artist blocks
contouring for your cheekbones your nose
a lot of things happen I also tried to
contour it but then I ended up just
turning it inside out
Thanos is for the trickiest yeah it was
very difficult I think the hair turned
out pretty well because you always have
very little hairstyle I love the neck
style yeah it's so cute if you look at
the back don't here's your outfit it's a
cute little butterfly print and I
finished it off right here I closed it
with a nice little chin mm-hmm all right
guys so which one do you think resembles
us more here I should give you this one
because oh yeah well you got to hold
them to our faces so you can see okay
careful I don't want to just vote on
YouTube cool and click who do you think
is the winner which one looks the most
like us where's the voting thing I'm
uniting down there not right I think it
will be up where's the ayat here well
guys thanks for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this we've been making some
really fun videos together so be sure to
go check out Rose Channel I'll put all
of the links in the description and also
annotations wherever those happen to be
you know what I'm really excited about
mmm the fact that we didn't use the
second potato yeah because that means we
get to bake it for ourselves
yes baked potato lunch yes please and I
got all the toppings in my fridge I got
a ton of topping love it this is uh this
is something that I never thought I
would be doing Justine this is amazing
thanks for coming up with this idea
because I never knew you could carve a
potato I didn't either now I'm gonna go
watch carving potato videos on YouTube
let's go down a rabbit hole let's go
with potatoes thanks for watching I'll
see you guys later
fine
[Music]